الى قسم الولاده في مجمع ناصر الطبي جئنا
بعد استهداف هذا القسم باحدى القذائف
المدفعيه التي تم تكثيفها خلال الساعات
الماضيه ضمن مسلسل القصف المدفعي خلال
الايام الماضيه الذي شهدته هذه المدينه
هذه القذيفه اخترقت السقف الرابع لقسم
الولاده في مجمع ناصر الطبي وكما تشاهدون
داهمت هذا المكان اخترقت السقف واخترقت
هذه الجدار ومن ثم جاءت على هذا السرير
الذي كانت تعيش عليه احدى الناجيات من قصف
اخر في منطقه ما من خانيونس
بترت قدمها وكانت يعني تواصل العلاج وهي
ربما من الناجيات القلائل في ذلك القصف
اليوم استهدفت بهذه القذيفه واصابتها
مباشره في راسها الامر الذي ادى الى
استشهادها وكما تشاهدون هذه القذيفه التي
لم تنفجر ولو انفجرت لكانت في هذه المنطقه
مذبحه
حقيقيه لكن هذه هي المره الثانيه التي
تستهدف هذه المستشفى بقذيفه ولم تنفجر
ساعات الصباح كانت ايضا سقطت قذيفه في
باحه من باحات المستشفى التي تضم كثير من
خيام النازحين اصيب اثنان من المواطنين
ولو انفجرت لكانت ايضا مذبحه حقيقيه نحاول
استطلاع ما جرى من الدكتور محمد زقوط
يعطيك العافيه دكتور الله يعافيك ايش اللي
صار يعني كما ترون هذا قسم اطفال اطفال ب
تابع لمستشفى الولاده والاطفال في مجمع
ناصر الطبي واطفال امنون ونائم في غرفهم
طبعا احنا يعني وضعنا بعض الاطفال اللي
عندهم اصابات في حرب ومنهم الطفله دينا او
دنيا ابو محسن 13 سنه هي نائمه قذيفه
دبابه مباشره اخترقت السقف واخترقت الغرفه
المجاوره الحائط من الغرفه المجاوره ومن
ثم اصابتها في راسها قذيفه مباشره وانتم
ترون دماغها قد تناثر على الحائط في جريمه
بشعه يند لها الجبين طفله مصابه ببتر في
ساقها فوق الركبه بعد قصف منزلها واستشهاد
اهلها وهي اسمها دنيا يعني كان طوال الوقت
تتعافى وا نعطيها شيء من الروح ومن الامل
ان هناك حياه وان هناك امل ولكن العدو في
هذه الليله قضى على كل هذا الامل حتى هو
لم يوجه لنا تحذيرا ولم يوجه لنا اي امر
بالاخلاء والاشتباكات دائره في منطقه شرق
خان يونس ولا يوجد اشتباكات في المنطقه
هذه ولم يصدر اي تحذير الى اهلها ولم يصدر
لنا اي اشاره ان هناك خطرا ما هذه قذائف
يطلقها العدو واهي رساله واضحه للمستشفى
انكم ايضا المستهدفون ما ذنب هذه الطفله
وما ذنب هؤلاء الاطفال وما ذنب النازحين
في خيامهم اذا اقدم العدو على ارتكاب
مجزره ومجازر اخرى في هذا المستشفى واصر
على انه يريد ان ينهي الخدمه الصحيه في
مجمع ناصر فهذا يعني انه يريد ان ي كل
مظهر من مظاهر الحياه والخدمه التي ممكن
ان تقدم لجرحانا ومرضانا في قطاع غزه
بالكامل اذا هو السيناريو يعاد من جديد
الذي كان قد استخدم من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في مجمع الشفاء الطبي
وللمصادفة
هل يشير هذا الاستهداف وتكثيف الاستهداف
وان كان بقذائف لم تنفجر واسفرت عن هذه
النتيجه هل يشير الى ان ذلك بدايه لمسلسل
محاصره هذا المستشفى وبالتالي استهداف
كامل اقسامه ومن ثم الاجهاز عليه حصاره
اقتحامه ام ان الامر لا يعدو كونه كما قال
الدكتور محمد زقوت بانه استهداف لكل ظاهر
الحياه في في المناطق الفلسطينيه باكملها
بعد ان جمع كل المواطنين الفلسطينين في
الجنوب والوسط الفلسطيني من النازحين
وبالتالي الان بدا يستهدف المستشفيات هل
هذا هو الهدف هذا بالتاكيد غير معروف لكن
بالتاكيد
الايام وممكن الساعات القادمه يمكن ان
تحمل لنا اجابه على هذا الموضوع وائل
الدحدوح
الجزيره مجمع ناصر الطبي